guitar hero live is a complex machine
with a lot of moving parts and a lot of
new ideas something both the franchise
and the entire rhythm game genre
desperately needs some of these new
ideas really work while others failed
pretty miserably
which makes Guitar Hero's long-awaited
return a consuming often overwhelming
sequence of incredible highs and
unbearable loads the game offers two
completely separate experiences in the
form of a traditional structured
campaign and an ever evolving music
platform that basically layers gameplay
on top of official music videos that
first component like the game itself is
called Guitar Hero live presumably
because it sets each of its 42 tracks
against first-person style footage of
real-life actors in theory this should
instantly immerse players in the
Rockstar fantasy of playing on stage and
for thousands of fans but one I was
generally too focused on the gameplay to
notice everything happening in the
background and to when I did notice I
frequently just cringed everything from
the costumes to the acting to the
unskipable concert intros feels
painfully forced and inauthentic every
single person smiles aggressively with
canned enthusiasm while giving you the
most comically exaggerated thumbs-up
you've ever seen it's so campy it
actually borders on parody - the cheeky
self-awareness and weirdly crowd
reactions come in just two flavors good
and bad depending on your performance
you're either an irredeemable
embarrassment or an untouchable rock god
there is no in-between
I appreciate lives attempt to do
something truly different and the new
approach did provide a few memorable
moments late in the campaign but the
execution basically ruins would go to
potentially been a cool idea thankfully
lives other major change pretty much
single-handedly redeems the entire game
it's new side-by-side button
configuration fundamentally changes the
way the game plays and delivers some
desperately needed innovation to a
stagnant Jarrah even seasoned music game
vets have to start from scratch which
renews the sense of reward that comes so
naturally as your skills develop that
sense of challenge and progress is a
huge part of the genres core appeal so
to completely revitalize those claws
is an unbelievable accomplishment that
said live doesn't completely nail the
new gameplay Ratatat the gate similar
sounds and guitar techniques manifest
differently in different songs which
made the learning process a little more
frustrating I also occasionally felt
like what I was playing didn't totally
match up with what I was hearing
the biggest issue though is the music
tastes are subjective sure but even if
you love every artist on Live's roster
many of the songs just aren't cut out
for Guitar Hero gameplay way too often I
found myself playing one simple
repeating hook over and over because
honestly that's how a lot of pop songs
are structured unlike rock songs they
were never intended to showcase the
guitarist artists like Skrillex and
Eminem are undoubtedly popular but their
tracks just don't make sense for a
guitar driven experience this brings us
to guitar hero lives other half Guitar
Hero TV which offers a far more
substantial library while the campaign's
42 on disc tracks consist almost
uniformly of top 40 artists from the
past five or so years gh TV includes old
six-string standards like Weezer the
clash and Pantera but there is a catch
any time you select a song from the now
playing section you have to spend a play
a 10 pack of plays will only cost you
about 2.50 cents and you can buy
unlimited plays for 24 hours for 6
dollars but you can easily avoid
spending money altogether by earning
in-game currency while playing gh TV's
channels which like the ancient days of
MTV play a constant pre-programmed
stream of music that you can jump in and
jam along with yeah you'll also earn
chunks of free plays periodically just
for playing the game at all although
there is no way to permanently unlock a
song so yes you can technically play gh
TV without spending money and you will
have access to its 200 plus songs if you
want to spend money the rates aren't
terrible and they might even make sense
for players who used to buy a DLC track
and then only play it once or twice but
honestly it's uncomfortable to even have
to consider whether a song is really
worth a play or to be forced to endure
content I don't care about simply to
access the content I want it changed the
way I thought about the entire
experience and for me
that lack of freedom undermined a lot of
the fun in spite of the campaign's
off-putting presentation and GH TVs
unpleasant microtransactions guitar hero
lives updated mechanics make music
driven gameplay fresh and fun again it
doesn't erase the game's problems but it
is a compelling reason to grab a new axe
and rock out regardless
you